one of our favorites is Josh Norman I
doing Josh going on buddy
I am great I'm better for talking to you
though it's crazy world's nuts Josh
well it's nuts I'll be honest with you
hey I'll tell you man oh man
but somebody need to go pound things
that's great like what do you think levy
on bail is thinking today just because
yeah you know I mean he's because he's
on Twitter and whether it's true or not
it's out there on Twitter that his new
coach and now new interim general
manager might have been the one to say
don't pay him oh wow
I don't know man that's not a tough
position to be here it really is but how
you really feel kind of thing you know I
read it I say this I rather see my
unmasks people than the ones who are
having masks if that's the case the best
the thing anything about it you know
what do you mean by that judging or not
yes meaning you know how to deal with
that person game I mean if that's really
how you feel and that's what you
standing ok I not a deal with you so
I'll go about that way instead of not
knowing
and then I found out something later and
I get stabbed in my back like least I
know up front what it is instead of
later hmm you got some masked people
from your past you want to lay down
right here just putting their thick out
there just saying it does the case that
I was ever to be in you know that kind
of form play a manís how people do you
think Josh Norman you're on the Rich
Eisen show how does Haskins look up
close we're here and he looks dynamite
Josh
yeah man can't can go I heard he can go
mana shoot he he's special
he's special I think that unit there
they have with bringing in from the
draft Japanese guys they brought in this
year cream of the crop guys I think this
is probably one of the best drafts that
he had in a very long time and the
franchise so it's been pretty important
to get the right guys in the building
just not any guys but the right guys I
think they did a good job at that
so when Haskins was drafted Josh and
there was a shot of him just being
disappointed that well not disappointed
shaking his head that daniel Jones got
drafted by the tyrants in front of him
and obviously the hometown team for him
Washington takes him how did you view
that as a now teammate of Dwayne Haskins
Josh well for him it was just one of
those things like you know I can't
believe it I don't know maybe it was
talks but you know he was going to the
Giants or how the case might be
but when talks don't form to what truth
is then you see it and as a player no
matter what we have a sense of it you go
about it's like we want to get taken you
know hi we want to prove where we are in
the rankings and you don't get taken
that way and you get looked at all man
this is a bummer like that's so
disrespectful but hey we're gonna make
you pay for it in the end that's kind of
how it was for him I think could be able
to be taking it that kind of way I'm in
this same situation you know but wasn't
a first rounder but I got dropped all
way down to the fifth knowing I was
better than the guys before me and so
therefore I was just one of those
feelings that he had but he was I oh
really
he takes someone else before me and the
quarterback so what I've done all year
and I showed and I proved myself okay
well we're gonna have some 40 for the
next team kicks me up and so forth you
know we were sitting right there at 15
was able to get them I think you're the
steel really I mean the kid can flat-out
play no matter who you is or what
or you know unit you and a big-time
Division one a ball you don't didn t
need I don't get proud oh that's a lot
of freakin touchdowns for anybody so in
order to have a player like that to come
in and play for us man it is huge some
is big-time so knows man what the kid
has I think he has a crazy you know he
got a crazy sky's the limit tool so it's
just you know he's feeling he gotta keep
pushing every day and I think he got
some great people around him and not
allow him to do that so you Josh Norman
Arn Washington with the Redskins Landon
Collins now in Washington with the
Redskins and now Dwayne Haskins in
Washington with the Redskins what do all
three of you have in common as to why
you're on the Washington Redskins do you
think Josh Norman well I know one thing
a frickin Super Bowl no I know I know
but who you know know I believe that I
believe that that's not what I was
driving at that's why I was laughing cuz
why I'm driving is who's responsible do
you think to put all three of you people
in Washington DC if you could guess know
who's the one who lets you walk from
Carolina and Landon Collins from the
Giants and then Draft at daniel Jones
instead of Haskins Josh who's that guy
oh not connected those dots Josh good I
mean they're I think everybody in the
world connected those ways and we have
an alliance with that guy mm-hmm
everyone watches right I think we need
to put him on salary
[Laughter]
salary I mean they mean to protect Dave
gentlemen all caught up in New York for
sure all cause he's winning
see that's right I mean I just kind of
triangulated that for you right there
cuz obviously if you do win a Super Bowl
the three you guys are gonna be a large
reason why wouldn't you think Josh yeah
I would think I would think you know the
more the more players you can get is
really good man better your chances are
but think is just all playing with each
other man and all have a sense of
urgency to go out there and compete and
be at the top of our game each and every
day you know ancient every time we step
on the steel just didn't top of our game
and then bringing people up to rise with
you you know I think that's the most
important thing just the rise of it all
and being there in that same mist
because we have the the crew do it I
feel like we got the pieces they
starting to come together we just got to
take another step as a unit man we got
to grow up and get some things going and
understand our role in and try to be the
best at it and everything else to take
care of itself
you know guys are a hungrier I feel like
they're they're back in their training
they're working hard
it's just now taking the right steps and
pieces put in place to be able to um you
know get into that championship form
into the playoffs man freak I missed
that thing so much how been back there
in a while
now I was just trying to get there and
what's you in the dance anything can
happen so um just trying to get there
first and foremost and then see what you
know what can we make noise in during
that time because championship man is
all what we we scribe for I think you
can actually fight about that me not I I
love college too man I love him I just
love the way he plays I think the to you
guys in the same secondary are gonna be
very difficult to handle I truly believe
that oh man he's a problem I mean
literally he's a problem so the more
problems we can have on
outside better I wouldn't say
necessarily explore the adversaries that
we face but we looking forward to him
and what he brings to the table this
year alone other guys but definitely got
like him I mean we've been talking this
offseason and give with each other so we
gonna make some things up NASA gone for
sure Josh Norma a couple minutes left
for the Washington Redskins quarterback
so what else you into you still are you
still into horses horse racing and stuff
like that - Josh I know you still out
there in Greenwood factory Island range
he um actually supposed to be riding
their hair coming up in June so okay
looking forward to it whether it's gonna
be gonna be pretty great for it we got
well yet you almost at 30 horses now
what you think what do you think about
the Derby finish and how they they
disqualified maximum security and and
and a monster longshot wins it all and
now neither are in the Preakness what do
you think of that Josh that is crazy
right that's never probably have didn't
feel that brazen that was just I don't
think anybody expected that in the turn
event so what happened because I mean
clearly they was racing down so at the
end it was just like nobody saw that
coming I don't nobody saw they know the
odds of that was just crazy well maybe
you know but maybe they'll change the
instant replay rules now in racer like
they did in the NFL based on the replay
controversy from from the NFC
Championship game and that leads me to I
guess one of my final questions for you
what do what Josh what what I'm just
gonna say don't do that man cuz we're
doing too much with that now that's what
we're doing way too much with that
instant replay stuff because we touching
it on our level and then it was all over
the baseball and now you want to put it
in the Kentucky Derby
no I
I was just kidding there that was just
my way of getting to replay and how you
are and how you are going to be yes what
do you think of the new rules that
somebody can challenge you for being in
for interfering with somebody after the
fact Josh I gotta say man doing too much
what for
I mean in a day yeah we know it's a
quick place of boom boom boom and yes
something has to be done but to replay
to the last two minutes one of the game
that can decide whether you go or not
from a tic-tac play oh my gosh man what
I said clean the defense back it's the
hardest position in the league
quarterbacks get the praise and yeah
don't get me wrong their position is so
screaming heart being back there and you
got away with the sinners coming at you
and you got complete the ball perfectly
every time that's hard I get it but dude
plan defensive back against the world
top athlete and getting call pass
interference left me right and then you
don't one that the other team goes for
because of a freaking play that happened
that you maybe like because a jersey
that didn't even come in the outcome of
the receiver catching a football and
they go flat on that come on man like I
I don't know how you do it like I really
don't is it never has been that way and
I always had a monster playing a game
the way the old guys played like the
greats the Hall of Fame breaks this how
they got there you know what I got there
you know they played game still go hard
hard-nosed and they played it the right
way and that's what we've been learned
now we got to play a game to where shoot
laundry fall on the floor every five
minutes crazy I don't know I don't know
what to do other than just play my game
I really don't I mean in the day we try
to do what we can to limit ourselves
from mistakes but they happen because
you're so aggressive in physical but I
don't know how you play the mission I
really don't my hands are tied
I just got to go out there and play my
game and hopefully you know I make the
you know
good many buddies I don't I don't know
what you see it's like any given moment
I don't know if it's the chip stacked
against me or not now well I saw I saw
how Richard Sherman responded Josh which
is like hey if there if if we're gonna
get flagged with this with the new rules
or with replay for defensive pass
interference they're the same intensity
better be for offensive pass
interference maybe a flag comes out and
what might be a pic play gets called
buzz down from the booth and wipes
something out in the fourth quarter -
Josh you know I mean I feel like you
happy out of it but again we don't make
the rules
we just play with whom - of course there
are guys that you know they never play
the game hey they want to make it keep
touching it and keep touching something
there's already you know I'm saying
perfect or imperfect to try to make it
perfect and and that's the thing man and
I feel like that's what we struggle with
something that is so great in this game
that we've been playing for so long for
so long I think we trying to make it
rocket science when it really is not
Joshua Josh you are the man you were the
best okay and and I don't care who tells
me even if it's gentlemen you know what
I mean and he told me he told me all it
took was two snaps at the Senior Bowl
seeing you in 2012 to know that you were
there grab toys for him to eat over
[Music]
there thing but a if it works for them
great I just say this keep continuing to
pay that man Josh take care of yourself
let's chat again soon let me know when
you're in LA okay absolutely as always
boss appreciation right back hit you
that's at Jay underscore no 24 on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239 under red
TV for free on BR live or download the
Rich Eisen show app